we have two new phones for you this week
the first one is the blackberry q10 now
if you're a business user this is going
to be the new blackberry your IT
departments going to be giving to you
later this year now the q10 is running
the first point one updates running
blackberry 10.1 and that's nice but it
doesn't matter because all the business
people who have been using blackberries
forever going to care about is that
fancy new keyboard the keyboard is
actually really cool it's a they have
slightly larger keys so it's a lot
easier to type and send emails to your
accountant or something about a meeting
whatever business people do with phones
that's we're gonna do with the Black
Bears you 10 yeah bbm and you the deets
right now bruh alright check you later
back now one thing that the hardcore
blackberry bold users might miss are
these large buttons that are across here
on the bowl those are gone out of here
so you're gonna miss some of the
customization but you have blackberry
10.1 on there you don't you don't really
need these buttons anymore anyway so who
cares so the q10 is a great upgrade to
the blackberry bold but it probably
won't get too many converts over from
iphone or any of those fancy android
rectangles out there yeah apple earnings
money now this is the samsung galaxy s4
it's a new android phone from samsung
and it's a premiere device for 2013 it
goes on sale later this week for around
two hundred to two hundred fifty dollars
depending on the carrier now if you love
the galaxy s3 you'll love everything
that Samsung has done with the new
version of the phone it's pretty much
better all around the chips are faster
it is a bigger screen to full 5 inches
it does 1080p video the batteries bigger
and it lasts longer also it has faster
chips inside and somehow the phone is
thinner and lighter than the last one
slider than air or balsa wood Samsung
has loaded the phone with a bunch of
software that response to your movements
so when you're browsing web pages you
can flip your hand like this over the
screen and the page will scroll you can
also switch between tabs by going from
side to side and if you're listening to
music you can advance tracks back and
forth by moving your
and it also follows your eyes so when
you're starting at the screen and you're
reading in the browser and you get to
the bottom of the page it automatically
Scrolls so that you never have to do
anything you just keep reading it works
like magic most of the time but it's a
little bit limited the whole moving your
hand to scroll pages thing it only works
in the default web browser it doesn't
work in chrome or Instapaper the kindle
app or Google Reader any of the places
where real reading happens likewise the
trickery you can scroll the pages just
by moving your eyes that only works in
the default browser doesn't work in any
of the other reading apps so comes
across as a bit of a gimmick the only
problem this is solving is oh my thumb
is so tired so all that stuff aside the
phone itself is awesome it's got a
really fast chip inside it's super power
efficient the screen is big and bright
and crisp and beautiful everything about
it is great we could totally recommend
it especially if you loved your galaxy
s3 and you can't wait to upgrade